hi guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the best exercise for that lower
belly pooch that flab in your lower part
of your stomach okay so many people go
to the gym and they're doing massive
amounts of sit-ups
okay and that's fine but it doesn't
necessarily get rid of that looseness
okay that loose skin or a little flab in
the lower part right here because if you
think about it when you do a sit-up
you are basically causing the lower part
of your your stomach to relax and become
even looser okay what we want to do is
reverse situps okay
like in this example right here where
the person is extending back so you want
to tighten up your butt muscles and
extend back okay over and over and over
that's going to tighten the lower
abdomen muscles okay and the skin then
over time it'll tighten that lower area
and so what I would recommend just
starting out to prevent any lower back
pain is to do it about twenty-five times
okay rest for a few minutes
do it 25 times rest do it 25 times
you'll feel that your stomach kind of
even goes in just from that alone so you
want to play around with this to make
sure that your lower back does not get
too painful because you're going back
and you're not used to it so make sure
that when you do this you tighten your
butt muscles up just to keep that area
very very stable now the next day if
you're sore of course weight to your
nuts or maybe do it every other day and
you keep increasing this slowly over
time to the point where maybe you're
doing 53 sets of 50 and you're really
creating a nice change in your lower
abdomen now as far as a diet standpoint
definitely a healthy keto and
intermittent fasting but there's two
tweaks number one you have to keep your
carbs below 10 grams not 20 30 or 50
grams you've got to bring it all the way
down because that will force your body
to really target the middle section the
middle section is where a lot of the
insulin receptors are and so we want to
bring our carbs down that's going to be
the most important action bringing your
carbs down okay so that'll help get this
leaner and leaner later and then this
exercise will tone and tighten the lower
flab that you have might have the the
second thing is
the quantity of fats that you have in
your diet if you consume too many fats
your body will turn those into ketones
and not your own body fat so you may
also want to play around with the
quantities of fats and start cutting
down your fats to the point where you
cut down your carbs cut down your fats
so your body has like no choice but to
really tap into the stomach if you do
this correctly within a few months you
can actually really tighten up in and
flatten your lower belly pooch alright
thanks for watching hey I appreciate
your attention and if you're enjoying
these videos go ahead and subscribe and
I will definitely keep you updated on
future events live events and webinars
that we're going to do very soon